ايضا بصفقاته التجاريه منذ عام 2006 عقد
ميسي شراكه دائمه مع اديداس لتزويده
بالاحذيه والملابس عام 2017 اخذت الشركه
هذه العلاقه خطوه ابعد مقدمه له صفقه
رعايه مدى الحياه حتى اليوم يقوم بالترويج
مرارا لبضائعهم وتقديم مناسباتهم نقدم
اليوم حذائك جديد واردت ان اسال ما هو
اكثر ما
يهمك صفات الاساسيه التي يجب ان يتمتع بها
الحذاء لتشعر بالراحه يجب ان لا يكون
مختلفا كثيرا عن الحذاء السابق يجب ان
يكون مشابها للحذاء الذي كنت استخدمه الى
حد ما ليس بسبب الراحه فقط بل اعتقد ان
الشيء الاساسي بالنسبه الينا هو ان نشعر
بالرضا والراحه تجاه ما نستخدمه احيانا
يسعى بعضهم
[موسيقى]
للحصول على العديد والعديد من الاختلافات
المميزه في حذائهم من حيث الشكل ليبدو
ظاهرا اكثر لكن ما نريده هو الراحه اثناء
اللعب لا شيء اكثر
هل تشارك في عمليه تصميم الاحذيه الخاصه
بك بالاضافه الى الجوانب الفنيه للاحذيه
في الحقيقه اجل لانه كما قلت توا ما اريده
واريده دائما هو ان اكون مرتاحا لما
ارتديه ولهذا السبب
اشارك في صناعته لمحاوله القيام بذلك على
افضل وجه ممكن الى جانب ذلك عمل ايضا مع
علامات تجاريه مثل بيبسي واي اسبورت بوضع
صوره وجهه على تلك المنتجات وظهوره في
اعلاناتهم التجاريه لكن عام 2019 افتتح
شركه البسه خاصه به المتجر المعروف بمخزن
ميسي والذي يبيع ملابس علامات تجاريه
شهيره يختارها ويصادق عليها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بسبب هذه الصفقات التجاريه الذكيه صار
ميسي ثاني اغنى لاعب كره قدم في العالم
بعد كريستيانو رونالدو مباشره لكن ميسي
معروف ايضا باكثر من صفقاته التجاريه كذلك
يساهم كثيرا في الاعمال الخيريه وقد انشا
مؤسسته الخاصه المسماه مؤسسه ليو ميسي
والتي ساعدت على دعم اطفال من بيئات فقيره
واطفال مصابين بالسرطان واطفال باعاقات
تؤثر في حياتهم
[موسيقى]
من حقه القول انه الهم ملايين الناس في
انحاء المعموره ومع انه احد اقل اللاعبين
كلاما واكثرهم تحفظا في الرياضه يعرف
الجميع اسم ليونيل ميسي بفضل عروضه
المذهله في الملعب ومساهمته الاجتماعيه
خارج الميدان استلهم جيل كامل من الفتيه
والفتيات والاطفال من ميسي ليلعبوا
وليتظاهروا بانهم ميسي في الفناء الخلفي
او الشوارع او الحدائق وربما ذلك هو ارثه
في ارجاء العالم